please welcome Gary Vaynerchuk good
afternoon
so there's a lot of places I think I
could go with this talk I'm gonna ask a
quick question or two just to
contextualize the audience in this way
can decide where to go with it
I also that mic have you guys been doing
Q&A with that mic is that in play okay
good so then I also want to do some Q&A
to bring where my thesis is maybe down
to a little bit more of the real life or
specific to the context of what you guys
do for a living how many people in this
room have no idea who I am or don't know
that much about me please raise your
hand
all right that [ __ ] hurts tough start
so chilly welcome Toronto all right I
kind of thought that would be the case
I apologize together 30 40 percent I'll
give a little back story of who I am
because I think it will help really
structure where I want to go with this
talk before I do that I'll make us a
statement that I think really matters no
matter what you do in this room at the
end of the day the reason I I care about
social media is because it's cell [ __ ]
and I think it's an important thing for
everybody understand I'm not a techie
I'm not that romantic about technology I
didn't own a computer until I was 19
years old I'm not super worried about
the gadgets or the technology actually
I'm super not interested in it at all
what I'm interested in is human behavior
and specifically because I'm an
entrepreneur and a Salesman I care about
what it does and how it does to end to a
goal within commerce right I think about
how it's impacting Parenthood and you
know and dictatorship and all the other
cool things but specifically where I
have a depth of knowledge is how it
makes you buy things you know Mayan talk
I like to tell people that I suck at 99%
of things in business that I'm actually
not that good at a lot of things but the
reason
I do think that I will buy the New York
Jets which is a professional football
team in America that will cost me
billions of dollars is because I have
one move one move that has brought me
enormous value in my career and that is
I bet on the things that I think all of
you are gonna do before you think you're
gonna do it how many people in this room
seven years ago said to themselves or to
somebody else the following thing and
remember lying is the devil how many
people said this thing to themselves or
to somebody else five six seven years
ago I'm not getting a facebook account
that's for kids I will never be on
Facebook raise your hand don't lie don't
lie don't get lazy on me of those 40
people how many of you are on Facebook
or have a Facebook account that right
there what you just saw is basically all
I do I know if this crowd was a little
bit older and there's some scattering of
it I'm all too
you know 15 20 years ago people said
they would never get a cell phone
there was a people adamantly were like
I'm not getting a cell phone this pager
is [ __ ] good enough right like that's
how people wrote like that's what people
believed and an on and on and on I
argued with my forward-thinking friends
two years ago the ones that pioneered
the POVs around Facebook and Twitter
I'll never forget this at South by
Southwest two years ago in a whole trim
room with twenty thirty gals and guys
that are supposed to be so futuristic
and we had an argument where I and one
other guy were on one side and the other
18 were another side on their adoption
and behavior around snapchat why they
thought it was stupid and they would
never use it all 18 of those forward
thinkers now snap me pictures of their
boogers or whatever the [ __ ] they're
doing right I mean this is something I
constantly think about and this is
something that will never change as a
matter of fact it's super interesting
for me to be here today
because under the context of this room
it's even more interesting to me let me
explain I was born in communist Russia I
grew up in America I grew up in the
liquor business I did grow my family
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business the reason I am no
longer 100% in the wine business is
completely
predicated on loss American laws around
alcohol are only second worse to you
guys right you know it's it's a it's a
really broken system and a lot of
protectionism through laws breaking down
opening then closing back up you know
when I think about the radio industry in
the US versus Canada and like the
Spotify and the our high radios and
things of that nature I'm always
fascinated completely fascinated by the
notion of people making business
decisions
hiding behind rules legalities or
governments because they're just a
matter of time and to me that is a
fascinating variable what I think about
and I'll get back to that a little bit
because I think that's specific and I
think we'll save that for Q&A let me
make this statement I know I still
haven't given you my bio let me let me
make this statement 99 for some of the
people in this room and 99% of the
organizations represented in this room
do not mark it in the year that we
actually live in all of my time is spent
all of my upside in my career has been
predicated on that one move that I told
you about which is doing the things I
believe you're gonna do before you do
it's not because I'm Nostradamus it's
because I pay attention and I get my
hands dirty in the reality of the
current marketplace I spend all my time
in two places the clouds and the dirt
nothing in between
I see erratically strategize and then I
actually execute with the nose channels
the Dave line came out last year the app
fine familiar fine raise your hands were
just trying to context here great when
vine came out last year I'm running a
300 person social media agency I am Who
I am and out of all the employees all
300 nobody spent more time playing with
vine on the first two weeks that it came
out and I get home at 11:00 p.m. from
11:00 p.m. to 2:00 o'clock in the
morning for three and a half weeks I
played on vine every day because the
thing that really pisses me off and I'm
about to get some smiles in the crowd
usually from the younger set the thing
that really pisses me off is when people
have points of view on products that
they don't even
[ __ ] use right I was and and that to
me is the most interesting thing back to
marketing in the year we live in let me
paint you a picture I was in a boardroom
the other day with a client
billion-dollar company markets to twelve
to nineteen year old females mainly and
a little bit of twelve to nineteen year
old male and I basically set out the new
year's plan where most of the money both
creative and distribution above the line
below the line is completely forced into
the environments of Instagram snapchat
and vine and I give all the data
compelling reasons I mean anybody in
this room that even has a pulse to
what's going on understands exactly why
all the money should be spent there
creatively and distribution wise but
knowing that I'm dealing with a fortune
500 company and an executive team that
doesn't necessarily know all those
nuances not lucky enough to have kids in
that age just yet kind of know your
audience
I give them all the data all the
rationale to why at the end of that
meeting gentleman looks in my mind my
face and he says Gary this is great he
goes I get it but you know what I don't
think we're gonna go with this because
very honestly I just don't get Instagram
so I look at his face and I said that's
great dick that's his name I go I go
that's great dick that you don't get
Instagram but 200 million of your
customers do and so I stand here in 2014
and I asked myself why in the world are
people marketing like it's two thousand
nine two thousand seven two thousand
four two thousand one 1999 and the
answers are clear some people just don't
see it I respect that but the answers
are much more complicated than that
aren't they there because there's
political reasons not to do it or my
favorite they don't understand the ROI
of it yet meanwhile we've accepted the
ROI of traditional mediums on ludicrous
horseshit with all due respect Allah
everybody here who's ever run the print
ad in their career has run a print ad
predicated on eight times distribution
of the print magazine or newspaper
because John
might leave Sports Illustrated on the
train and Ricky might come along and
pick it up and go to page 147 we've
accepted this we've accepted outdoor
media billboards I've spent plenty of
money on them in my career because some
dude stood on top of a building one day
20 years ago with a clicker clicked it a
bunch of times and we mathematically
predicated that out into the volume
growth of population over the last two
to three decades we've accepted Nielsen
ratings which I don't know for Canada
but in the u.s. 5,000 boxes representing
300 million people's television viewing
habits so we've accepted it in marketing
and advertising what any money with any
hardcore math discipline is going to
look back on in the future now that we
live in a digital environment as the
dark ages because the companies Amin
investor in uber and Birchbox and all
these other companies that have done
well or the retail company that I run or
the retailers that I'm involved with who
have direct response businesses where
you spend money and you see what it
brings back they're all pouring their
money into Facebook unpublished posts
right now meanwhile while everybody else
is reading Ad Age and saying Facebook
organic reaches down I'm not gonna run
anymore Facebook we are living in really
interesting times and most people aren't
executing on so many different variables
they can't show the ROI look I get it
you want to show the ROI of your
Instagram campaign and you've got
somebody disciplined above you that
doesn't know how to quantify it and you
walk in and say hey we did really well
this month we got 1,700 hearts that's a
tough thing to sell through I respect
that at the same token there is a
fundamental reason why big companies go
out of business because they don't mark
it and execute in the world we live in
it's why they don't they wait four to
seven years for people to create a
reporting mechanism to justify what's
going on in reality while everybody else
innovates and executes and takes their
business blockbuster didn't have the
data to tell them why to buy Netflix
for forty million dollars eight years
ago that put them out of business and so
we go on and on and on look this is the
same thing over and over I built that
wine retail business from three to sixty
million dollars because in 1996 when I
launched my library comm which was one
of the first e-commerce wine businesses
first of all that was ridiculous and
early most people in 1996 told me they
weren't going to put their credit card
into a computer and for the people in
here a little bit older than their 20s
remember really debating that first time
they ever did put a credit card into a
computer because the one thing we're
grossly under estimating in this room
including me who fancies himself and
knowing [ __ ] is that the Internet is
just begun how many people in this room
remember the world pre-internet you
actually remember living your life and
there was no internet raise your hands
raise it high yeah most of you most of
the people in this room remember the
world pre the Internet forget of a
[ __ ] snapchat or vine or Facebook or
YouTube or all the things we spend all
our time on talking about which all
didn't exist just ten years ago the
internet itself is basically twenty
years old and I know there's some nerd
in the background like oh I'm actually
nineteen fifty-nine
I know [ __ ] nerd but I mean when
normal people went on normal people have
been using the internet for about two
decades we're just starting and
everybody in here is grossly and I mean
heavily under estimating the culture
shifts we're living through these are
massive culture shifts and so the
behavior of our consumers in marketing
and how they decide to buy and most of
all in the way we communicate with each
other is massively changing massively
and our actions and the way we advertise
and execute and story tell don't match
the way we actually live our lives on
the consumer side your marketing and
trying to make [ __ ] happen very
differently than the way you're acting
as a consumer on the other side of it
because you have vested interest in the
success of the marketing over here and
you don't over here we are now using
technology to get away from marketing at
all costs how many people here now
besides
live sports and award shows watch most
television on their time you know PBR
TiVo Netflix on-demand
well how many people in this room watch
most television on their time raise it I
wonder why you to raise it I want
everybody look around we're talking
about 80% of this room how many people
in this room have spent 2014
fast-forwarding every single ad when
given the opportunity please raise your
hand a weird of all of you meanwhile my
clients at vaynermedia the biggest
clients of the world and in Canada in
every country meanwhile they are
fast-forwarding every users
fast-forwarding meanwhile they're
spending tens of billions of dollars
producing and distributing commercials
trying to reach you to tell you your
story and you're not seeing it even if
you're lucky enough that somebody
dropped the remote control off their bed
and the [ __ ] commercials got to you
even if that happens even if there's the
luck of that happening all of you in
this room the second that thing goes to
a commercial and they're telling you a
story that you don't want and you're not
there for you're pulling for your laptop
your iPad or your phone and you're
texting about what you just saw catching
up on email the thing that we're all
battling for whether you're EA or
stumble upon a radio station whatever
b2b you've got a platform PR writer I
don't care what you do the one thing
that binds every person in this room
every single one regardless of career is
we're all battling for attention the
commodity that everybody in here wants
the one thing that you all want every
one of you want in your career is
attention get my attention then tell me
why I'm so awesome why I should buy ads
for you why I think you're good why you
bring me value in what you're trying to
tell me and the supply of attention has
not grown as a matter of fact it's
decreasing because the volume of stuff
being thrown at us has exponentially
exploded over the last ten to twenty
years and now we have a battle we have a
supply and demand issue and so people
think that they can do the same old
thing they did ten years ago to break
through Direct Mail outdoor radio look
how many people in here now when they
drive listen to the music that's on
their phone how many people do that I'm
just curious that's about 25% of this
room that's about
25% more than five years ago right and
these friends happen and they change and
things happen and so I don't think
traditional media is dead
I don't think a commercial is dead I
don't think of billboards dead I don't
think a radio ads dead Direct Mail I
don't think they're dead I just don't
think they're worth the price they were
five years ago it's as simple as that
and that's business right outdoor media
do me one favor when you leave this
keynote when you leave this keynote do
me one favor when you're driving home
tonight
please look at three people when you're
driving I promise you to the three
people driving are looking at their cell
phone right people are looking at their
cell phone so you think they're looking
at billboards my friends people are
looking at billboards they're not even
looking at the [ __ ] road anymore
who here can't wait to go to their
laptop or tablet and click a banner ad
who's fired up
point zero one percent click-through
ratio when in our lives has point zero
one percent of anything been deemed a
good thing these are the reports back at
media buying agencies that everybody's
high-fiving that like oh not bad point
zero one I'm sitting like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about that is ludicrous
now let me paint you a picture of what I
mean by marketing in the year you
actually live in in 1997 I launched wine
library's email service how many people
here have done email marketing at some
point in their career been close to the
email marketing awesome a good amount
you ready for this one you'll love this
one
in 1997 four hundred thousand person
email newsletter
I had eighty nine point nine percent
open rates yeah [ __ ] that we could never
achieve now you know you're a hero at
thirty something zero right eighty nine
percent open rates like sixty three
percent click-through read like stuff
that you couldn't even begin to make up
right now you know why in 1997 there was
a different world I'm gonna make a
statement that I believe in more than
anything more than I believe that the
Sun will actually come up tomorrow I
know that marketers ruin everything and
I'm a proud marketer I am that I can't
wait to ruin snapshot do you know why I
do you know what yep I'm serious you
know why I stayed up for three days
three weeks excuse me on vine to figure
out how to ruin it that's the truth now
the nice thing is ruining it these days
is making native ads and it's getting a
little bit better as we continue to hack
of this culture but that's what it is
marketers haven't ruined it yet Groupon
and LivingSocial hadn't come along yet
and emailed you [ __ ] you didn't want
every day sixteen times a day marketers
ruined email marketers by that purpose
are ruining social media social media
looked a lot different in two thousand
six and seven than it does right now
it's what we do it's how it rolls so
when I had a hundred thousand followers
on Twitter compared to the million that
I have now I got dramatically higher
click throughs and engagement on the
stuff that I tweeted out because the
supply and demand curve was in a good
place
we just ruin things it's what we do
banner ads I'll talk about banner ads
in 1996 when I ran my first banner ads
with 24 percent click-through 2.4 out of
every 10 people that went to a website
click the banner ad because like who
what's this [ __ ] thing right like
that's what it was and when I and when
Google AdWords came along I bought the
word wine for 10 cents and known it for
nine and a half months before anybody
bid me up and now it's a 14 dollar word
right and then when banner retargeting
cookie ads came along I cookie the [ __ ]
out of all of you when people thought
you ate that [ __ ] right I knew what it
was I used it and it worked better it
converted more we weren't used to being
followed around people even sent emails
like wow you guys are buying a lot of
ads everywhere because we didn't even
know that was the behavior yet and so
over and over and over it's a very
simple game innovation comes along
there's opportunity first move advantage
there's a value proposition it gets more
expensive Facebook dark posts if you're
an app developer that really understands
what's going on how many people here are
familiar with the term Facebook dark
posts raise your hand all right so let
me really get into it Facebook
unpublished posts is the proper
terminology dark post is a slang term
Facebook right this second you have the
ability to target every single person on
Facebook you don't need a single one of
them to be a fan you have the ability to
make a picture a video an infographic
whatever you want and then target the
living [ __ ] out of it
to data levels that we've never seen
before down right - like MasterCard
behavior you want to sell some soap
pretty cool to like target somebody who
actually bought soap in the last 30 days
wanna buy soap that wasn't your brand
soap in the last 30 days you can target
the 300,000 people in the last 30 days
that bought a soap that's not your soap
and you get to put something in front of
them targeting at a level we've never
seen before the conversion rates that
I've seen on facebook unpublished posts
in the last three months art a single
best digital asset marketing thing I've
seen since Google AdWords in 99 2000 yet
the hyperbole of organic Reach drop
going down has all the marketing rags
talk about why it's bad and why debating
people if they should double down or
triple down or get completely out this
is the common story over and over again
and so what I implore
you understand is this it's very simple
you know I know you know I'll talk about
Walmart I know it's more of you that
us-centric play what works out of
business the biggest retailer in America
is at a business it's just a matter of
time now right they didn't do the right
strategy to the world we're about to
live in over the last decade Amazon did
and the game is over it's over they have
the end whoever has the end customer
wins Amazon has the data has the
customers they're building 13 warehouses
in the US right now to do same-day
delivery within the same day of your
delivery and October because we're lazy
we value time that's what we care about
when I invested in uber people like
nobody's gonna pay for that I'm like
they may not pay for a premium black car
service
but people gonna buy time because you
value money your health and time
that's what uber sells time that's what
Amazon is gonna sell at same-day
delivery time that's what we live in and
so we're living through massive massive
culture shifts one that I think people
are grossly under estimating one that
people get very comfortable in oh we
thought all these things were gonna
happen then they don't and then they
really go out of business
the reason Borders bookstore went out of
business in the US was because Amazon
came along in 95 got all the hype the
2000 Internet bubble came Amazon lost 91
percent of its value in the stock market
not in actually how they were doing with
customers in the stock market and
borders decided they were gonna take
advantage of this opportunity and they
let Amazon do their distribution online
they didn't build their own capabilities
and it was unpaid them there's literally
borer executives I know that will said
they'd laughed in the boardroom when
they made the deal that Amazon was gonna
do all the work for them and they were
getting paid meanwhile and was over just
collecting customer data collecting
customer data and in 36 months borders
was basically out of business the key
thing is this everybody wants to know
what the ROI is right now and just
because there isn't an ROI at this exact
second doesn't mean that it's not
valuable to do the lack and I come from
retail family business where it wasn't
about how many impressions you got or
how many
goneand [ __ ] can it was about if we
didn't sell [ __ ] Pinot Noir
we weren't gonna eat right so it was
results-driven
and the only thing i ever talked about
and thought about and the only way i
story told and the only way that i
marketed was about lifetime value and
percentage of wallets spent something
that I have heard zero of since I've
come to corporate and agency America and
that to me is the opportunity who here
actually cares about their customer who
here wants to have a customer for ever
who here wants to execute and it starts
with having a great product but it also
means how to properly story tell in the
world we actually live in contextually
to the platform the amount of people in
this room that believe they have a story
to tell they make a video or have
something to say and then use social
media as distribution is by a high
percentage most people here look at
Facebook and Twitter as distribution
channels I'm gonna do something over
here I'm gonna take the link and I'm
gonna post it on Facebook consider and
derive people they treat social like
email marketing what they completely
lack and we're all the upside is and
what I basically wrote about in the book
is storytelling contextually within it
so the results happen within it no
reason to send a mouse somewhere else
people I mean people really get an
emotional romantic point of view of
driving people out of social to their
website so their website can do their
thing when at the end of the day is long
I mean would you care if you sold
somebody in your house or at the park
doesn't really matter as long as you
sold them and so there's just a lack of
strategy in my opinion what by the way
one man's point of view one man's point
of view that spends all his time
thinking about why in the world are my
friends raising a million dollars
starting a company and then heavily
hurting companies that have five hundred
million dollars in market cap why are we
living in that world right now why are
we living in a world where companies
within thirty six months are able to
massively disrupt the incumbent that has
so much more money and so much more
legacy so much more brand equity and so
much more infrastructure and it's
happening because the Internet
itself the internet itself has
eliminated the costs of infrastructure
to go to the consumer and story-tell in
an efficient way and in a quick way and
meanwhile when I spend all my time in
not trying to allow my customers to
spend money on dumb [ __ ]
because that's what they do all day long
we're spending money on dumb [ __ ] and
we're not storytelling to where the
consumer is and this is happening at
scale the fastest growing demo for 40 to
60 year olds right now is the fastest
growing demo on Instagram it's Tim's
fastest growing demo is a 42
six-year-old the people that are taking
the most selfies in the world growth
curve in the last six months are forty
three point three year old females 43
year old females are the highest growth
curve in selfies moms are [ __ ]
pulling it out and snapping the [ __ ] at
a selfies at a scale that nobody thought
and so we're disregarding a very
important fact I want to really pound
this one home for you I really want you
to hear this one because way too many
people are gonna pull the well my
customers not their card or my demos not
their that's a favorite [ __ ] card
that I want to [ __ ] burn right now
let me explain to you what's going on
with your [ __ ] card right
you're my customers not there let's talk
about that the highest conversion of
consumption on Facebook right now is 46
to 63 year olds because they've gotten
to the habit and they're not leaving
it's why your mom still has a yahoo
email address right that kind of [ __ ]
number two number two if you look at the
behavioral data the clothes she buys the
way she goes out and how often her
routine the way she engages on social
right now the average and this is an
American step so I don't have a frickin
I apologize the average bless you the
average the average forty four-year-old
female in the u.s. behavior maps to the
average twenty nine-year-old American
woman its behavior only 10 years ago we
are living through the youth of vacation
of our society for anybody here over
3540 they can remember their parents at
some point at that age
everybody in here that's capable of it
think for one
right now of your parent at the age you
are right now and I promise you they
were much older than you their behavior
was much older we're living through a
massive unification and it's because of
the shift in technology how many people
here have a daughter or son that's 15 to
22 years old raise your hands
thank you so for the 30 of you do you
remember the conversation you had two
years ago when you said hey little Ricky
I don't care how you talk to your
friends but when your mother and father
call you pick up the damn phone remember
that one
just curious how'd that work out for you
when I explained to the rest of crowd
how it worked out there are grown-ass
men in this room in their 50s that
texted lol and OMG in the last 24 hours
that's what happened Uncle Bob's like
where's my emoji Kahn right so shit's
changing and it's funny to laugh and
it's interesting to watch and you're
seeing it anecdotally in your life
you're going out you're seeing it you're
seeing it you're tasting it and you're
disregarding it in your execution and
your marketing and running your
businesses it's just the way it is and
honestly I know there's a huge crossover
in here I know there's a twenty to forty
percent of this audience that knows it
sees it but can't do anything about it
because as the layers go up it gets
killed somewhere along line because
there's no ROI
there's no belief in it it's not safe
you can't do it still doesn't stop from
it being wrong and so that's it that's
how I see the world I see a enormous
opportunity for the people that want to
market in 2014 and 15 want to respond to
the behavior want to understand how many
people here have done SEO or SEM
marketing in their career Google came
out recently saying that Google AdWords
in the last six months are down 20% and
click-throughs behavior marketers ruin
everything
Google was pure remember Google 99 2000
2001 2002 never do we search something
and the first result was always what you
needed
it's how they got there that's how they
became Google now ads everywhere and you
clicked them at first right because they
still were kind of on track now it's
such a mature more
getting funnel that a lot of those ads
aren't as valuable to you you're not
clicking them as much and now Google
search SEM AdWords are going down in the
other direction no different than
everything else no different than the
social ads in the next half-decade no
different than everything else the
opportunity the singular opportunity is
to execute in the reality of the
marketplace not too early
I know augmented reality is coming it's
coming I know smart refrigerators are
coming I know smart pants are coming but
I'm not marketing smart pants real quick
because I've seen it already smart pants
are you guys ready for smart pants
Jesus you're fired up
let me tell you real quick about smart
pants imagine putting on your pants in
the morning and your pants texting you
and saying hey Lou eat a salad today fat
ass smart pants smart pants connected to
your phone in a world where we all pay
with our phone which is basically a half
decade problem at this point where most
of the POS systems just have to be
updated so when you're paying with your
phone and your phone's connected to your
smart pants and you put on your pants in
the morning and you're running through
the airport like I'm going to be in an
hour and I haven't eaten all day
so I'm hungry so I'm gonna go really
quickly to a Burger King or something of
that nature order a Big Mac and then I
go to pay and it's declined and it again
reminds me to eat a [ __ ] salad that's
a real reality or or the smart
refrigerator where you put a Bud Light
into your refrigerator six pack and you
pull it out you put another Bud Light
six pack in your refrigerator you drink
it over three days you pull out you put
another one you drink it over three days
now the refrigerator knows your drinking
habits about two a day and when you're
down to two the refrigerator reorders
the Bud Light for you to be delivered at
your home so who's that gonna disrupt
the Liquor Control Board possibly my
wine shop for sure Costco Walmart Tesco
guys we are living through massive
disruption that everybody's glossing
over and wants to not say anything's
happening because they have vested
interest in it's staying the way it is
because that's what they're comfortable
with or romantic about it's how they
make their money or their bonuses but
none of that ever
it's just how innovation works it's how
capitalism works none of that stops the
progression and if you're closely paying
attention the progression of innovation
has never been at a speed of this level
because the infrastructure is now coming
into play this is the second Industrial
Revolution everybody's sleeping on it
and I highly recommend you wake the [ __ ]
up thank you
you